[Musique]
tu n'as aucune idée de ce qui t'a
d'accord
monsieur oui quand sera les règles
je pense que vous imaginez les
conséquences grâce à sa survie
communication
et
qui ne devrait pas être si ce dicastère
content de te revoir aussi
il faut que même après cela ce sera
vraiment loin d'être acquis
tu n'as aucune issue la grande table
veut les mener
pourriez-vous créer l'ambiance pour
notre invité mais avec plaisir les
services sont toujours suspendus bois de
quoi as tu besoin
d'armes beaucoup d'armes
c'est que vous pouvez avoir déjà
oui
vous risquez d'avoir une mauvaise
surprise
attendait de vous rencontrer en
depuis bien
elle pour l'instant pas une fois vous ne
m'avez déçu
on peut continuer comme ça si ça tire
c'est impossible
oui
et tout ça pour quoi à cause d'un petit
chien s'était pas qu'un petit chien
[Musique]